Alright, I'm gonna go to the airport and pick up uncle Seymour. Who's that? He's dad's grand uncle he's got one leg
Seymour this is not your port wheelchair, and I'm actually gonna need it back. Oh someone needs it more than this guy okay
Got a big one doctor C. Another day another life
Hello?
Father of the groom. You got a sec? Uh... Yeah
Can you believe it's in five days? I've got this. All good here pal.
Okay, I hope everybody likes the hotel you having a wedding at a quality lunch toaster
For slice the two diamonds this bad boy is gonna light up the dessert table
Where's the magician I
Never hit my children one of the good things about not being there
You said to call the bills any problem the leak spreading if the rest of the place booked
It's fine for a couple hours, but not a whole night. No it's good in moderation. It's fine
We did you think give $0.99 wedding and the booze bottles for Giants let me bail us out at it
Every father looks forward to making a wedding for their little girl I
Have been able to help my kids their entire lives
In this one
There's gotta be a decent hotel like a.. Boy I thought we talked about this - I can handle it we get the call
We can cancel that oh. Yeah, oh
So like that I do a little
Okay big smiles you guys get it together. Okay? Yeah, just give me one more Drive